[Music]
this has always been an obsession
everybody collects something
and mine just happens to be antlers
[Music]
my name is jim phillips and i'm the
antler man
i have over 16 000 antlers
[Music]
i didn't kill all these animals to get
the antlers
i'm not much of a killer
deer and elk and moose and antelope shed
their antlers
every year
and grow a new set of antlers
i just started walking out in the hills
and i would find one and pick it up and
bring it home
there is no
harm to the animal
[Music]
i have good days and bad days the most
deer antlers i ever found in a day was
87
but i've hiked 11 hours
and never found an antler
[Music]
i keep my antlers in a shed
that i built at my house
it is 60 feet long and 30 feet wide
there's a pattern to everything in here
and the way the antlers are laid out
that's the art
the reason i guess i display the antlers
the way i do
respect for the antler respect for the
animal itself
the shed may seem full but when i look
around i can still find places to put
the antlers
as long as i can get out and
get around in the mountains i'll
continue to collect
i get the same thrill today
59 years later
as i did when i was a 10 year old and
there's very few things you can say that
about
my wife has plans on me stopping
my daughters have a plan on me stopping
but i have no plans on ever stopping
[Music]
you